il ne sera plus possible à qui veut de
louer un logement sur la plateforme
Airbnb au Québec dans une lettre
adressée à la ministre du Tourisme
Caroline Prous l'entreprise indique
qu'elle retirera de son site toutes les
annonces de logement non enregistrées
auprès de la coopération de l'industrie
touristique du Québec les eaux devons
dorénavant fournir un numéro
d'enregistrement à défaut de voir leur
annoncé de supprimer dès mardi
cette annonce survient au lendemain
d'une rencontre entre les dirigeants
d'Airbnb Canada et la ministre du
Tourisme
et près d'une semaine après le tragique
incendie qui a fait quatre morts et
trois disparus dans le vieux port de
Montréal la plupart des unités de
l'immeuble étaient loués par l'entremise
de la plateforme Airbnb une pratique
pourtant interdite dans ce secteur de la
ville je suis satisfaite de la décision
derbnb de ce conformer à notre
législation je reste toutefois ferme sur
mon intention de resserrer la loi sur
l'hébergement touristique écrit Caroline
Prous sur Twitter la mairesse de
Montréal Valérie plante indique que ce
geste ainsi que le récemment des règles
par le gouvernement du Québec était
nécessaire pour lutter contre les Airbnb
illégaux le problème n'est toutefois que
partiellement résolu croissait de
chercheuse
québécoise qui voit le jour donc ça va
être de voir avec ces plateformes là
avec quoi ces collaboration là fortement
critiquée par les parties d'opposition
dans la gestion de ce dossier le
gouvernement logo s'est engagé à réviser
sa loi d'ici la fin de la session
parlementaire pour obliger les
annonceurs à devenir un numéro
d'enregistrement à la CICQ sous peine de
reprise d'ail malheureusement
Réal pour pouvoir y arriver mais c'est
une très bonne nouvelle les autres qui
louent un logement durant plus de 31
jours ne sont pas visés par cette
nouvelle mesure selon Airbnb ici Daniel
Piaggio Radio-Canada Montréal